a wild stallion from Mount Charleston
was killed by federal officials over the
weekend the horse was beloved in the
community and residents want to know why
less aggressive means weren't used
Joshua paguerra looks into the events
that led up to Fletcher's death
in this community of Mount Charleston
these wild horses are a staple among
visitors and residents but the
euthanization of one recently is causing
an uproar among those that live here why
did this happen where did this happen
how was it that this came to be Aria and
Sorensen is in shock over Fletcher's
death in longtime Valley resident she
loves horses and hope to adopt Fletcher
so I never saw him in my interactions
with being aggressive BLM tells me it
acted within protocol when it euthanized
a horse but doing so was its last resort
Fletcher was killed on Sunday after he
entered private property but according
to the BLM he began acting aggressive
deeming Fletcher a huge threat to humans
and private property I do have a lot of
questions during our interview Sorensen
received a call from BLM they went over
what happened we just need the truth and
the facts and we need to change the laws
to start protecting these animals
because this is their land and it's not
fair for us to come in be BLM says they
had received complaints against Fletcher
starting last July Cheryl Abate lives in
Mount Charleston and teaches animal
ethics at UNLV she's also upset what
happened is sort of a symptom of
um just a problematic way that we've
used and view animals in our society we
view them as disposable is there parking
or in the picnic area you will see some
of these wild horses in the lower part
of the mountain due to all those snow
that Mount Charleston has received so
far according to my Charleston Joshua
figuero eight news now